et mouettes les battements d'aile qui
brassent un mélange de sel et des flux
marins où l'on croit discerner une vague
exhalaisons de terre mouillée de
cannelle et de roses
des bateaux
des châteaux des frontons découpé en
escabeau comme pour aller faire le
ménage des nuages
bon bah requérant plein ciel sur long de
remuer par les cloches
des arbres en fleurs des tours de beurre
des relents de cale ouverte et des
souvenirs de compagnie des indes qui
flotte autour d'un brave coulée dans le
bronze des canons pris à l'ennemi
nous sommes
aucun doute là dessus en hollande pays
bas pays plus
laborieux détenteur de trois géographies
celle que le ciel lui est donnée celle
que la mère lui a reprise et celle qu'il
a fait de ses propres mains avec l'aide
de la providence du moulin à vent et de
la pompe à eau
de trois géographies et comme tous les
autres peuples de deux histoires l'une
officielle qui sait dans le bruit et la
fureur
et l'autre que l'on ne trouve pas dans
les manuels
l'histoire de tous les jours
et
oui
qui va bientôt s'ouvrir ici dans cette
église par un raclements de sabots sur
les dalles
e
oui
des regards curieux tourné vers la porte
par ou 20 entrées le dernier né des
petits hollande du zuiderzee
il va recevoir sur le front les gouttes
d'eau du baptême
bénéfice de la rédemption et vaccin
contre le déluge
au bout
coucou
et
après quoi son histoire pourra commencer
il va grandir aussi vite que l'on peut
grandir au cinéma
vous le verrez bientôt
en âge de jouer avec les allures et
en âge de faire des shows tease et de le
réparer
oui
e
et
et avec ses yeux bleus comme il se doit
vous le verrez bientôt en âge de se
promener en clair de lune
et en âge de prendre femme dans un grand
éclat bousman de rire et de folklore
il
oui
tu
c'est
on a
la noce terminé
le piston et l'accordéon ayant rendu le
dernier soupir
vous le verrez en âge de gagner sa vie
de pêcheur
dans la mer qui le porte il nourrit en
méditant quelque peu de le noyer
m
vous le verrez enfin
en âge de prendre de large
1 l'histoire qui n'aura jamais
d'historiens et que la musique va vous
raconte
et
mais